there are more than 130 fires burning in
the province and teams have prioritized
37 of them with 861 firefighters on the
ground and 20 water bombers as part of
the fight
the battle is not over public security
minister Francois barnardel says
authorities are concentrated on two
regions including normetel a town 720
kilometers Northwest of Montreal in the
abitibi region and shibugumu in the
central northern part of the province
he says all our teams and Equipment are
on the ground including reinforcement
from New Brunswick to ensure we save the
normital community more than 13 500
residents have been evacuated mainly in
northern and western Quebec
um
he says the situation remains
complicated but the weather over the
next two days could help firefighters
according to environment Canada key
areas in the province could see Rain by
Tuesday we are talking about 10 to 20
millimeters uh will that be enough rain
for those places uh that's really
um up to the provincial authorities to
determine when will also play a huge
role
says for now the winds are on their side
that will also help the air quality
throughout Southern Quebec
um and those areas getting the rain air
quality in the greater Montreal area
remains stable with rain expected by
Monday about 300 more Wildland
firefighters from the United States
Portugal and Spain are expected early
next week Elizabeth ogallis Global News
Montreal